good morning and welcome to mit's first
sustainability connect event this is
really a pivotal moment in mit's history
we're poised to renew and expand the
campus with the opportunity to build and
renovate to the highest building and
energy performance standards using the
most efficient design strategies while
embracing new technologies addressing
system-wide opportunities such as
stormwater and land management and
advancing sustainable design standards
we're striving to redefine sustainable
transportation that's a shout out for
larry and for an institute that already
boasts a high percentage of single
occupancy commuters today
and is dick in the audience is he is he
here yet well i may have to repeat this
later on when it gets here because i sat
and counted and today is 100 is day 190
of the construction of the mit nano
building which is on track to being leed
gold certified and positioned to be the
most energy efficient clean lab facility
in the country and that's been
some some good and hard work from that
team the climate change conversation
uh was it was initiated last fall to
stimulate a campus-wide discussion as to
how mit should make a significant
positive contribution to confront
climate change locally and globally and
this conversation taps into the
knowledge and perspective of faculty
staff and students alike and the
innovation initiative was also launched
which targets mit's ability to solve a
range of critical challenges in energy
the health of the planet human health
and beyond and the environment
initiative was initiated to engage a
range of connected fields
from cities to oceans and from
engineering to economics from ecosystems
to energy and these are just a few of
the related research and operational
activities that are happening within yet
extending be all beyond the walls of the
institute today
and this morning you're going to hear
from faculty and staff involved in each
of these initiatives and how they
advance mit's ambition to create
game-changing sustainability solutions
both on and beyond our campus but
there's more because mit is embedded in
a community fabric that is committed to
sustainable community development
cambridge is one of 10 communities
participating in the ecosystem in the
eco district's target cities program
which is designed to amplify and
accelerate district scale community
engagement and create replicable models
for next-generation urban revitalization
and many of us in this room are working
tirelessly to shape this initiative
we have been working with the cambridge
city official officials and residents
together with representatives from
harvard and the development community on
grappling with the definition of and
what it would take to actually achieve a
net zero emissions community and lastly
the city commission one of the most
comprehensive climate vulnerability and
resiliency studies in the country to
inform future growth and development
throughout the city and you will learn
more about the findings of this the
unveiling of some of this
data this afternoon and so it's our turn
now to grapple with what we do with this
new knowledge along with the embedded
uncertainty within this within these
findings as we work to inform our own
decisions into the future you know we
launched the office of sustainability
just 18 months ago on a platform to
position ourselves as a bridge between
many of the initiatives that i just uh
reference and to really be a facilitator
of a process moving forward and so we
launched on these on this platform
of aiming to transform by creating a new
and powerful model for sustainable
innovation
we launched on a platform that strives
to generate a new path forward by
responding to unprecedented challenges
of a changing planet and educational
landscape
we launched on a platform of innovation
and how it can be
one that can be created but also we have
to prove ourselves all along the way
and we have no doubt we know that mit is
positioned to pioneer this way forward
and our opportunities to create new
metrics and new standards in building
performance ecosystem services education
research and systems thinking
so at mit we have the about we have the
opportunity to embrace our ability to be
a scalable laboratory in which to devise
pilot implement and evaluate the best
sustainable urban strategies of today
and the emerging next gen strategies for
tomorrow we're positioned to advance the
science of climate change and its
consequences understand the impact of
climate change on human health build and
test new energy models develop and test
carbon-free technologies such as solar
wind geothermal power but also find more
efficient ways to use carbon-based fuels
to improve building materials design as
well as improved vehicle and power plant
technologies and a commitment to
sustainability is a long-term one this
is a really important point people want
this to always be a definition but we
what we bring to this as an office is we
have to recognize and understand and
consciously assess our priorities
uh along the way which at times can be
perceived at odds with one another and
that's the engagement i've had with most
of you around this room uh in the in in
the meetings we've sit in with these
working groups and it's the interactions
between human health environmental
quality or environmental degradation and
of course fiscal responsibility and
these are complex and it requires us to
think deeply about how we ensure the
growth of our human potential while
maintaining the integrity of the natural
systems that support it
so the role of the office of
sustainability is actually not to
convince all of you to install as many
kilowatt hours of solar power panels as
possible and have all of you riding a
bicycle to and from campus
though related recommendations may
emerge
but rather the role of our office and a
commitment to becoming a leading
sustainable institution is to build the
institutional capacity and it's a
capacity that enables us to understand
and develop structures to ensure the mit
community including each of you can
swiftly and comprehensively identify
analyze and implement decisions that
both serve us today
and enable us to thrive in the future so
keep that in mind today as we jump into
this recommendation phase we're not
urging to just jump into the solution we
have to understand what's the capacity
what are the trade-offs that we're
considering and how do we continue to
keep this moving forward but then we
need to measure our impacts and develop
the most reliable and comprehensive
metric system possible and return again
to the beginning of the process so we're
continuously proving improving and
learning and improving again
so i want to also share this with you
as a model as as a
visual aid to bring into your working
group discussions today
and this is a commitment a commitment to
sustainability is also commitment to
understanding and orchestrating these
nested impacts so when we frame and
debate what is possible we're
considering the fiscal environmental and
human health impacts at various scales
so we're looking at materials building
site campus city region nation and then
of course the global context so many of
you are working in depth within a
particular scale and so that was this is
one of the the big moments i've had
being at mit is just the level of depth
and knowledge that each of you bring to
the table but then our role is to make
sure that we're nesting nesting that
knowledge in this context some of you
are have specific information i can work
with have in-depth dialogue with some of
you on roofing materials and others we
can actually have different dialogue
around water systems and so we must
learn to assess how to leverage the
biggest impact at each scale and we will
revisit this framework frequently within
the working group sessions
both today and moving forward
the other piece which you'll hear more
about briefly is the governance
structure and so who's in the room today
so many of you who joined us today are
representing your department either as a
member of
or a resource two one of eight soon to
be nine sustainability working groups or
committees that are in motion this year
and so some of you are even on
some of you are even on more than one of
our groups which we appreciate
and
so take note is that our office like i
mentioned earlier is is we've really
begin to build these bridges from the
mit energy initiative to all of the work
going on in cambridge the environment
initiative climate change and then this
is our framework to the right is campus
systems living lab and community
collaboration which is how we organize
ourselves since we launched in october
we've been bringing you through a
process that has called upon each of you
to assess current conditions to study
best practices we've been looking at our
peer institutions at
industry expert expertise we've been
seeking inspiration through uh through a
variety of faculty through best
practices new theory we've been looking
how best to connect across ideas and
groups
and then we're starting the process of
now drafting recommendations to move
towards implementation so today is
choreographed in true mit fashion we are
attempting to recreate what building 20
was once referred to as a magical
incubator we've organized the day so as
to orchestrate what jane jacobs once
described as knowledge spillovers and we
as an office and as a community embrace
the belief that innovation emerges from
collisions so we invite you to collide
with one another today
around the common challenge of
determining how can mit be a
game-changing force for sustainability
in the 21st century it's truly an
amazing group of people that are in this
room today as you look around if you
haven't met one another i've had the
fortune of actually meeting everybody in
this room at some point in just my 18
months here and i feel so fortunate i
mean this is merely the launching point
for the question but we will continue to
revisit this question many times today
and in the months and years ahead and we
are truly on this path and committed to
becoming one of the leading sustainable
campuses in the world it's an ambitious
vision i know but it's one i have no
doubt we will be able to achieve i've
only been at 18 at mit i know 18 months
but i now have the mit spirit it's
really infused in my system and it's
contagious i've never felt so confident
about being able to develop such a grand
vision before i studied a lot of mit i
read everything i could get my hands on
in my first number of months here and
this is one of the quotes that really
stood out to me which is as the world
calls out for answers to questions more
complex than ever before mit catalyzes
change it delivers solutions and
innovates for tomorrow
you